let's start class so um last week we
discussed the
possibility that um Trump will become
president and we discussed that um if he
does become president in a second term
there will be a very strong
likelihood that the United States will
go to war with Iran now um the question
today is okay okay Trump wants to go to
war but will the US military agree
ultimately it is the Pentagon that must
implement this war and if there is
enough opposition from the
military then um it is very hard for
Trump to push a
war I want to make the argument today
that the military will go along with the
war and it has to do with what happened
in 2003 okay so let's let's go back to
the last time that America fought a
major war it was the 2003 invasion of
Iraq called operation Iraqi Freedom okay
so at that time uh President George Bush
and his people uh Vice President Dick
Cheney uh Secretary of Defense Donald
russfield and his Deputy Paul wolitz
they want this war and they go to the
Pentagon and and and say listen we we
want this war give us a plan and the
Pentagon uh the generals they're very
experienced and conservative people and
in general when you fight a war there
are three things you must focus on okay
the first idea is mass
forces when you fight a war you want to
overwhelm your enemy
so when we say Mass forces we basically
mean
infantry and armor most wars um are
fought using tanks and
soldiers and um the Iraq Army at that
time had about 370,000
soldiers okay and in general the general
rule thumb when you invade a country is
you want to have a three to1 Advantage
okay
the reason why is that when you invade
an army sorry when you invade a country
you need to hold territory and resupply
your soldiers okay so you you need to
advance you also need to hold
territory um as well as we we Supply
your your troops and have reserves okay
so the general rule of Thum is that if
your enemy has 300,000 soldiers you need
about a million okay so that's the first
principle second principle is the idea
of
you want to avoid
encirclement the worst thing that can
happen to your soldiers is if they
become encircled by the enemy okay
because then it becomes impossible to
defend yourself right and the third idea
is
protect supply
lines most of war is actually just
Logistics how do you get uh oil and fuel
and weapons from here to there okay
supply lines so these are the three
major uh principles that you must focus
on when you fight a war so when the bush
government asked the Pentagon for a plan
the Pentagon went to uh the drawing
board and said to invade Iraq properly
we need about a million
soldiers okay and
and Donald russfield who was Secretary
of fense and his Deputy Wolford said no
we're going to do it with less than a
million soldiers give us a plan
with uh that requires less infantry and
the Pentagon said okay um well we
shouldn't do this but the most we can do
is about 00,000
and wol said nope go
lower and and eventually Roni and
Wolford said I want we want you to fight
this war with 100,000
troops 130,000 troops okay the Pentagon
said to RFI and wolitz this is
insane we will be outnumbered 3 to one
when we fight this war how are we going
to avoid encirclement how are we going
to mass forces how will we protect
supply
lines and Ron field and wolitz who are
not by the way professional soldiers
they've never they've never really
fought a war before they're like well we
have this Theory a new theory of War
called Shock and
all and the idea of shock and all is
that all militaries are hierarchies okay
you have command and control so you have
the head and then you have the body and
then you have the arms and the legs well
if we can go and cut off the
head then the entire Army falls
apart and we can do that because the
nature of War has changed what the US
military specializes in what gives us
the advantage is three things or three
things okay first is Air
Supremacy we control the skies because
we have the greatest air force in the
world okay but second what's most
important is
technological
omniscience omniscience means to know
everything we're God the reason why is
listen we have satellites that can see
everything on everything on the earth we
have technology that allows us to East
drop on all electronic communications
when you talk on the phone we can hear
exactly what you're saying we know
everything on the ground that allows us
to have the power of God okay that's the
second thing the third thing
is we have special
forces so special forces are soldiers
who go into enemy territory and are able
to Target and
direct air power against the
enemy okay
and we America have the best special
forces in the
world and so with these three things we
have a new doctrine of War we can fight
war in a new way that's never been
fought before but which will guarantee
that war will be quick we'll do it very
quickly cheap it won't cost that uh much
money and third decisive we will complet
completely destroy our enemy okay and
the Pentagon was like you guys are
insane this is not going to work this is
a theory guys whereas this idea Mass
forces avoid and CC protect supply lines
we've been doing this for like thousands
of years this is just experience this is
just history this is reality
guys this is just a fantasy all right
but rsfi and wolf
insisted and they said you must fight
this war this way and they insisted and
it turned out that this plan that the
Pentagon most military planners thought
is absurd insane
unrealistic worked 100% the way it was
supposed to
work okay the second GF war in 2003
lasted exactly 3
weeks very
quick the US military with only 130,000
troops was able to destroy an army of
370,000 in three weeks okay that's one
second is
that
America lost at most 200 soldiers and
most of it was due to Friendly Fire okay
it was accidental this is insane this is
not never happened before only 200
American soldiers died at most whereas
tens of thousands of Iraqi
soldiers um died okay and the third
thing that was most impressive is some
called Thunder
runs okay this is just America flexing
okay or showing off so what was
happening was that America was so
dominant that you had these American
soldiers in their uh armored vehicles
drive into Baghdad the capital city and
they just drive around Circle it and no
one could stop them and this is what
they call Thunder runs okay and they did
three of these it was purely an act of
intimidation but it's also just showing
off okay it's like you're in to fight
and you decide you know what I'm so much
stronger than this guy I'm going to do a
back flip okay I'm so bored by this guy
I'm going to do a back flip funder runs
okay so these three things Show the
incredible
superiority of destruction of shock and
um
awe okay so um how's America able to
achieve uh all this well I mean the
first thing is uh the idea of air
supery so one bomb called cluster
bomb can wipe out an entire D tank
Division and the reason why is that a
cluster bomb inside has about four 40
bombs and these 40 bombs are equipped
with GPS so what they can do is each of
these bombs can go and find a tank it
will latch onto a tank and blow the tank
up so this one cluster bomb which
doesn't really cost that much money can
destroy an entire tank division
uh by itself
okay um the other thing um
is Special Forces so the theory is that
special forces if we make them the
central core of our military that would
have a devastating impact and and it was
true so what was happening was that
special forces could drive around and
look for military insulations by
themselves okay we're talking like a few
people and then they could order in a
air
strike okay and then the the um planes
were blowing
up
so shock and all was
extremely um
effective but the problem is that people
don't really
ask what did s sdam Hussein do wrong why
was this so effective against Saddam
Hussein and there actually
three
reasons
okay to think that what happened in
2003 was not a revolution in military
Doctrine not a revolution in Warfare but
just
a unique incident in war that doesn't
really tell us that much okay in other
words what was happening in Iraq could
not be replicated okay and there were
three three three reasons why
the first is that Saddam Hussein had no
ear
defense okay he had no ear defense he
didn't have weapons to counter the
America's Air Supremacy the reason why
is that in
1991 Sadam husin fought a war against
America called the first Persian Gulf
War okay Operation Desert Storm and his
army got destroyed by American Air
power and at this point America could
have chosen could have chose to go
invade Iraq and overthrow Saddam Hussein
and America didn't so sdam Hussein
learned two
lessons uh
from the Persian Gulf War which is
number one I can never beat America
there's no point in trying if America
wants to beat the crap out of me I can't
stop it okay that's the first thing
first thing he learned second thing he
learned is that America probably does
not want to overthrow me because if he
over frze me it would destabilize the
country it would destabilize the region
you would allow terrorists into the
country um you would turn my people into
terrorists you would Empower
Iran so there's no way that America
could overthrow me would want to
overthrow me so let me just focus my
resources on suppressing internal
descent okay so he completely forgot
about about America so even when it was
clear that America America was about to
invade he still did not put up any ear
defenses because he didn't have any ear
defenses okay so that's a first thing
that was unique about the 2003 War okay
second thing is
that Iraq is a
desert that makes it ideal for Shak and
all right ear power can go anywhere you
have satellites that can see
everything Special Forces can just drive
around okay so a desert makes an ideal
situation for Shak and all and the third
thing is just
surprise no one in human history has
tried to fight a war like this okay and
so no one
knew how what was going to happen so an
example is that um special forces were
in Western Iraq blowing up missile bases
because the concern was that sdam
Hussein would direct all his missiles
his scuds against Israel okay so so much
damage was being
inflicted in Western Iraq that Saddam
Hussein believed he was so confident
that the that the that the main American
Military was actually in Western Iraq
when in fact they were in eastern Iraq
so he diverted all his forces to Western
Iraq and left backd completely open to
attack from the
East okay so no
one had fought a war like this before
and no one knew what to expect okay but
obviously you can you you can only do
this once right okay so the there are
three special conditions uh to make us
think that struck on all in the
2003 um Iraq war was just a one-off it
was unique
okay
unfortunately uh the Americans don't
know this okay right the Americans are
like well all this does is prove our
Theory to be correct okay so over so
after
2003 America focused its military
Doctrine
um its military on shock and all okay so
the example is Special Forces so before
2001 America had about
38,000 Special Forces today it has
73,000 okay that's a lot because America
has a total Army of 1.3
million um mil the budget for Special
Forces Black Ops okay it was about two
billion in 200 uh 2000 and today it's
about 13.7 billion so it's almost an
increase
of uh 7even times which is a lot but um
this is just the public official
number because special forces are Black
Ops they can operate
outside
supervision of the military okay so in
other words their their actual budget is
probably 10 times possibly 100 times
more than the official
budget all right now now Special
Forces um I want to talk very briefly
about why Special Forces is a problem
okay now traditionally militaries have
been very strict hierarchies and there
are good reasons for this okay you have
to enforce order and discipline right
but you're also concerned about the
military overflowing the government
right that's always been a problem
throughout history so you must maintain
complete control but when you do that um
you
create um a lot of problems in the
military it is unable to react very
quickly to hostile situations okay if
terrorists come and attack you your
military can't actually go and defeat
them it's too slow okay um sometimes
there are hostage crisis okay so so
throughout the 70s a lot of airplanes
were getting hijacked by by terrorists
for these circumstances you need special
forces okay soldiers who are outside
your immediate control who can respond
immediately to crises that's why you
have special
forces
okay but in general you don't want that
many special forces because again
they're outside the control of your
military okay they're
independent sometimes of your military
they have a lot of
law of space to maneuver and to be
independent um now why are special
forces a problem it's because the people
who volunteer for special forces are
different from you and me okay to put it
very lightly so for example let's look
at um two one of the top two special
forces in the world called SAS okay this
is British Special Air Services the most
one of the most elite certainly the
oldest Special Forces um in the world
the other is
Delta and so you volunteer for Special
Air Services you're you're you're
applying okay and their first test is
this the first test okay there are many
tests but the first test is you have to
run six marathons in five
days okay oh that's just beginning you
also have to carry a backpack of breaks
while you are running six marathons in
five days okay and you're like okay
that's hard oh one more thing you're
running the marathon on a
mountain okay you understand you have to
run six marathons in five days with a
backpack of
bricks and you have to go it on a on a
mountain somewhere okay so even at that
first test there have been some
individuals who've gone
crazy okay you have to put them put them
in a hospital because they've gone
crazy but that's just be the first test
the last test is always torture they
will be
tortured to see how much they can resist
torture okay because obviously when
you're captured the enemy is going to
torture you to get information out of
you right what what are you doing here
uh who is your commander are their other
comrades with you okay you always be Tor
tortured so they also have to withstand
torture there's some other tests so for
example in the French special
services uh one test is that you will
have to wear a bullet bulletproof vest
okay and you will have to um hold a clay
disc right and then your comrade will
shoot a gun at
you most people are like I'm not going
to do this okay so in other words words
the people who are special forces
they're different from us
physically but they're really different
from us
psychologically they have a different
mentality so one special forces was
interviewed by a reporter And the
reporter asked him why did you choose to
become Special Forces and his answer is
well it's either I do special forces or
I go rob backs one of the two in other
words special forces are
individuals who are addicted to risk and
violence and guys in America there's
73,000 of them running around the world
trying to protect the American
Empire
okay
so uh Special Forces have increased and
it's really changed the nature of
uh the American Military so it's so it's
good for America because now what shun
all allows America to do is be
everywhere at
once and you'll never see them okay so
for example uh the example is when
Gaddafi was overthrown in the 2011 Libya
War okay that was special forces but we
don't know this because the special
forces were hiding the background okay
ear power against uh Gaddafi so in other
words what Shaw and all really is is
it's more than a theory of War it's
ultimately a theory of
Empire America is an Empire but
unfortunately most Americans don't want
to admit that because being an Empire
means doing bad things to innocent
people and what shakun all allows is for
America to be an Empire without the
guilt of being an Empire okay you have
special forces doing all the work
necessary in order to maintain this
Empire without people actually knowing
right so shakol is really a theory of
Empire as opposed to a theory of War
okay so does it make sense to you guys
so far
okay any questions so
far
yeah okay so Seline asked a great
question um are there what what there's
more special forces is it because
there's more people who want to be
special forces or is it because America
needs more special forces the answer is
both okay so so again the um
America um after the fall of the Soviet
Union no longer had a peer competitor so
the understanding uh of America is that
from now on they would have to fight
Rogue regimes okay so small Nations that
don't really listen to
America um and these nations have to be
toppled very quickly okay so the
examples would be uh Iraq Iran North
Korea okay the AES of of evil so America
started to shift um its Doctrine to
Shadow Wars okay Wars that you don't you
don't really see uh but which would be
effective in
toppling um the um the regimes you don't
like okay and so a lot of the resources
were shifted into into special forces
that allowed more people to enter uh
Special Forces
okay does that make sense okay all right
any more questions before I move
on all right now the question then is
all
right shock and all where does this come
from it comes from uh one of the
greatest disasters for America called
the Vietnam War okay so from
1965 until
1973 um there's a civil war in Vietnam
between North Vietnam which is communist
and South Vietnam which is basically
basically a a Us control puppet state
okay and America sent soldiers from 1965
to 1973 to protect South Vietnam from um
insurgents and
Rebels and at the height of this war
three million US
soldiers um had to be deployed okay um
and at the height in 1969 500,000
soldiers US soldiers were in country to
fight against the rebels and the
insurgents okay
58,000 US soldiers died in this war
three
million at least three million
Vietnamese died in this war two million
of them were civilians innocent
civilians okay
over
300,000 US soldiers be were wounded okay
they went home without without legs
without
arms and they were
traumatized and this was an extremely
controversial
war in the in America because they were
trying to fight the war using standard
military Doctrine Mass forces right so
they institut did something called a
draft so if you were a young American
you had to go fight in this war in
Vietnam but you didn't know why you had
to go fight this war and ches are that
you would either die or you would lose a
body part in this war so it became
extremely unpopular in America the other
thing is that there were a lot of
journalists uh in Vietnam during this
time they were reporting on how America
was killing Vietnamese for no reason so
the most famous story is something
called The myly Massacre where American
soldiers went into to a viese village
and killed everyone there okay 300
people 400 people okay and and this was
happening actually quite a lot so there
was widespread anger and protest in
America at this time which ultimately
forced America to withdraw in
1973 okay and
um the US military was very angry about
this war because the thing about
generals is they don't like to lose
Wars okay when they fight Wars they want
to win at all costs and they felt that
they were betrayed by the
country they were fighting hard to
maintain the American Empire to fight
against communism and this was bringing
wealth power and Prestige to America but
the American people the American
politicians the American democracy
Republic refuse to make the necessary
sacrifices in order to maintain this
Empire and so the AL many American
generalist felt betrayed by what
happened in Vietnam okay now there's a
very famous incident during this war
called the Pentagon
papers in
1971 in 197 won a group of American
analysts okay they were these are
military analysts working in the
military they cly got together and they
and they tried to compose a secret
history of the Vietnam War and this is
called the Pentagon papers this was
meant to be classified this was not
meant to be read by the public but one
of them Daniel ellsburg linked it to the
newspapers Washington Post in New York
Times and they published it and people
were angry by the Pentagon papers
because what the Pentagon papers said is
one America has been secretly fighing
this war for a long time okay so many
presidents including Eisenhower Kennedy
and lynen Johnson were expending this
expending this war
without public approval without
Congressional approval okay so there's a
lot of deception that's the first thing
second thing is
that the politicians the presidents knew
this war was not winnable you couldn't
win this war okay and the reason why is
that
these um Vietnamese peasants they were
unbeatable because what what they were
doing was they were digging tunnels
underground and then when American
soldiers were coming they would just pop
out these tunnels shoot at them and then
disappear back into the tunnels okay it
it was like as though they could swim
underground they were not beatable
second thing is that they had an
unlimited supply of weapons and you're
like wait a minute
um these peasants don't have weapons and
the answer is they got these weapons
from their enemies okay so the first
thing is that these soldiers these
American soldiers were in in the jungle
and they were carrying backpacks of
ammunition right and sometimes they
would lose a fight or they run away in
the jungle because it's very hard to
carry these backpacks of ammunition
right they would drop these ammunition
and guess what you're now arming the
enemy right because these peasants would
pick up these ammo and use it themselves
that's the first thing second thing is
that the US
military dropped more bombs s on Vietnam
than in World War II combin okay more
more bombs were dropped in Vietnam then
in World War
II combined okay does that make sense
and about 20% of these bombs didn't
explode and if they didn't explode the
enemy could pick them up and transform
them into
landmines and the it was these landmines
that were killing more Americans than
anything else that's the second thing
third thing was
that the uh South Vietnamese Army was
extremely corrupt so they were taking
these American weapons and selling them
to the
rebels okay so then the question then is
if you can't really see this enemy
they're everywhere okay they can swim
underground and if you're supplying them
yourself so matter no matter how much
weapons you can bring into this country
how are you going to win this war the
other thing is that these peasants were
getting angry at you because obviously
in this war you're killing a lot of
innocent people right who happens to be
their brothers their sisters their
children their
parents okay so as this war was dragging
on the Vietnamese were becoming more
embittered and more
Angry so there's no way you were going
to win this war okay that's that's a
pentagon paper second thing the third
thing is okay the question then is
if um these American Presidents these
American leaders know for a fact that
this war cannot be won why were they
fighting this war why were they
contining to fight this war and the
answer is unfortunately the answer is
credibility
okay we don't want to lose face
guys okay we don't want to lose face if
we
withdraw from Vietnam if we admit that
peasants in pajamas can beat us Soviet
Union would laugh at us China would
laugh at us the entire world would laugh
at us we don't be laughed at so that's
why we're staying in this war
okay so to summarize what the Pentagon
papers said okay three things one is
that the American government lied to the
people and um turn this into a major war
that's first thing second thing is that
America cannot possibly win this war
Okay the third thing is that um
America's only in this war So to avoid
losing face that's it there's no
strategic
purpose there was no strategic
objectives from fighting this war it was
just like we don't want to lose face we
don't be laughed at that's it okay so
obviously when the Pentagon papers were
released to the public everyone was
angry okay and the anger was so
tremendous that America had no choice
but to ultimately withdraw from the war
and so the Pentagon felt betrayed by
democracy the politicians were more
concerned about winning elections than
about winning wars
okay people could protest
and Def and and defy the military they
refuse to make the sacrifices necessary
to win this war the
media um could insult the
military
so so there were many in the military
who F that listen if we are to maintain
the
Empire we need to divorce the Empire
from
democracy okay
Empire and democracy do not get
along if we want to win a war our
greatest enemy is not the enemy but
Democracy in America and that's why you
have shock and awe right because because
the entire point of shock and awe is to
minimize casualties and if they are
casualties you can't see them because
they're all blown
up right and it's quick so it's
impossible for people to um start to get
angry okay sh and all means that America
no longer has to make any
sacrifices you no longer need the
consent of the people to fight the war
you don't even need Congressional
approval to fight the war you can now
escape the shackles of democracy in
order to do what you must to protect the
American Empire higher okay does that
make sense so shakun all was really
response to Vietnam War and what shock
and all means is
that the Empire is no longer burdened by
democracy special force can go and do
what what they must without any
oversight and consent from the people
okay does that make sense
guys okay so this is a shun law is
really a theory of Empire what America
must do in order to
maintain um its Empire around the world
any any questions before I move on about
this okay so s asked a great question
which is okay I make the argument that
shol only works in uh Iraq
right um and what would happen in other
words okay so the thing about America
for the past 20 years it's it's been
mainly fighting wars in the Middle East
and it turns out the entire Middle East
is a desert okay all right so this Shu
and all policy has had tremendous
success in uh Iraq and then in
Libya okay because America
overthrew Gaddafi and Libya and also
it's also had some success in Syria as
well okay so from the perspective of
America we're really only fighting Wars
in a desert shock on all is fine
okay but our next class we'll discuss
Iran and Iran is not a desert it's
mountains and I'll show you that shock
andol is not going to work in Iran okay
but that's next class okay does that
make sense all right any more questions
yeah
yeah yeah okay so Jack makes a great
point which is okay yeah but most people
would say that America lost the Iraq War
because of the Insurgency right okay so
okay that's a great Point okay you can
make the point that America for the past
20 years have lost all wars in Iraq and
Afghanistan because they have not been
able able to control the Insurgency okay
but the problem with this is that shakan
all it's not designed to stabilize
countries shakol is meant to topple and
Destroy countries do you understand and
so the argument can be made that the
real intention of shakun all is to make
sure that no power in the Middle East
can arise to challenge America
Supremacy okay so yeah in Iraq the
insurgents um ultimately won but is Iraq
a functional State and the answer is no
right is Libya a functional State no
there's still civil war going on in
Syria right so that's a great that's a
great Point okay and and it it it comes
down to what is the ultimately what is
the ultimate design and intention of the
empire is it to replace regimes or is it
to destroy countries and you make the
argument that shakol is really designed
to destroy
countries and not to um replace regimes
okay does that make sense Okay now
what's important to understand is um
that one of the theories of the invasion
of Iraq is to bring democracy to the
country okay but the problem with that
is from the start they did everything
wrong okay so first thing is they they
really didn't have enough soldiers to
maintain peace right in the country so
there's a lot looting so the entire
country broke down second thing is that
during the air campaign um America
destroyed all the infrastructure
necessary for society okay so including
water supply including electricity grid
why would you do that if your intention
was to bring democracy to the country
right the third thing is that the very
first the American government did when
they took control over Iraq is something
called deification okay which is say
that if you used to work for the old
government government you're now out of
out of job hey the Iraqi military you're
now
disbanded but and and then the question
then is ha if your ultimate objective is
to bring democracy to the country why
would you destroy all political
infrastructure in the country why would
why would you destroy the ability for
the country to govern itself as well as
to maintain order as well as to feed the
population why would you do that okay so
an argument can be made that the real
intention was not to bring democracy to
Iraq it was just to destroy Iraq to
maintain American Supremacy as well as
to um teach others a lesson don't mess
with us we'll come and destroy you okay
does that make
sense okay but this is something we we
will discuss later on okay in another
class okay all right all right let's now
move to the last topic which is the
theory of Empire so this is not the
first theory of Empire America had it's
actually the second theory of
Empire um the first theory of empire was
in
1991 remember that
1991 America
launched um an attack against Sadam
Hussein because sdam Hussein invaded
Kuwait right
so um at that time 1991 the Soviet Union
had collapsed America was the only hamon
was the only Power and it presented a
new theory of Empire how America will
rule the world okay so the first idea
is
limited
strategic goals or objectives okay so
for example in 2003 when American
America invaded Iraq its strategic goals
were pretty uh unachievable okay it was
basically like we're going to bring
democracy and peace to Iraq and the
Middle East okay whereas in the Persian
Gulf War led by the father right George
her uh Herbert Walker Bush the the first
and only goal was to
remove s Hussein from Kuwait that's it
okay we're not going to go to try RQ and
top s Hussein we're not going to inflict
punishment on sadd Hussein all we want
to do is remove him from Kuwait okay
that's the first thing second thing is
that America did so with a coalition of
countries okay dozens of other countries
were part of the war and America played
a leading role but it also had to defer
to its Partners okay so for example um
countries like Saudi Arabia who
participated in the war were like
there's no way we'll topple Sadam
Hussein we we'll only stop at Kuwait
okay so the United States deferred to
its Partners okay and the third thing
was and this is the most important is
that the ultimate leader was the United
Nations the United States had to go and
make a case to the United Nations the
United States the United Nations gave
its consent to the military action okay
so the United States made the argument
that this is not a US military action it
is a UN military action okay and so the
important principle is
to maintain the rules based in National
order okay so what America said at that
point is yeah I know we are the greatest
power in the world I know the Soviet
Union has collapsed I know that
militarily no one can challenge us but
with this power comes great
responsibility we must show humility we
must show discipline we must show
restraint our priority will be to
maintain the national rule space order
because this will bring Prosperity
freedom and stability to everyone okay
and that means that if we use military
op if we use the military it will only
become because it's the last resort the
last option and only for a limited
strategic
objective we will only do so with
partners and we will only do so under
the umbrella of un Authority okay so
this is the first theory of Empire you
think about it wow
great What a Wonderful World
right here's the question then
why did
America not do this anymore why did it
switch to shock and a shock and a is
basically unlimited strategic goals
unilateral military action right we
America will do this by ourselves we
don't really need
anyone okay and then America just just
basically bowling we make the
roles why did America do this why this
transition from the first theory of
Empire which is great it would allow
America to rule the world forever to now
the second theory of Empire which is
pissing the entire world
off
why okay so this is really hard to
understand okay but but let's use an
analogy okay so Jack is my son okay and
I'm a billionaire I have 10
billion why do I have 101 billion it's
because one I'm smart okay I'm smarter
than everyone else two I work really
hard okay and three I bribed a lot of
politicians so I have $10 billion but
I'm like 95 years old and I know I know
I'm gonna die okay so I invite Jack
who's my son to dinner and I say to Jack
Jack um I love you and I want what's
best for you I'm going to die very soon
and you will inher herit my Empire okay
and I want you to know
that you don't have to worry about
anything Jack because I have 100
advisers who control this Empire who
manage this Empire and they are great
they're experienced they're
loyal they're
strategic every year Jack they make 10%
for us okay so $10 billion they make a
billion dollar for every
year when I go they're still going to
matage this Empire for us and you know
what they're going to give you every
year Jack $100 million to do whatever
you want you want to go buy an airplane
do that you want to go by an island do
that you want to party with movie stars
do that you can do whatever you want
okay so Jack as my last wish as my dying
wish I want you jack my son who I love
to promise
me that after I die you will listen to
my 100 100
advisors okay so Jack do you promise
me you promised me right and then I die
and and then what is the first thing
that Jack will do the very first thing
he will
do come on guys
hard your first thing you will do okay
is fire everyone get out of here okay
what's the second thing you will
do you're gonna hire all your friends
Jack okay you're gonna hire all your
friends okay and what's the third thing
you're you're GNA
do you're GNA do something really stupid
okay you'll be like you know
what my dad only made $10 billion those
advisors only make 10% a year
I'm going to invest in Bitcoin I'm going
to invest in AI I'm going to invest in
the Chinese stock market the Chinese
real estate market and make hundred
billion dollar okay and then he loses
all the money you
understand all
right it it this happens all the time
guys okay right ask yourself if you're
dad were rich and he was about to leave
you a lot of money would you listen to
professional people no no you like no I
want to have fun okay so the question
then is the first fear of
Empire okay which said that for America
to maintain its Empire it must
demonstrate to the world humility
discipline and
restraint why did they get rid of this
and move to shock and all which is like
we'll do we'll do anything we want why
why why would they do
that because it's fun okay do you
understand what is the point of having
an Empire if you cannot blow things up
for no
reason there's no point we have the
greatest military in the world let's
just blow things up for like no reason
okay all right now
there are three fundamental problems
with shock and a okay the first problem
is
that you become
overcommitted do you understand you
believe that shun all allows you to be
God you can be anywhere at once fighting
all wars okay you're overcommitted
second is you lack strategic
Focus meaning that you actually don't
have a plan you don't know what you want
to do with this Empire you know you just
want to maintain this Empire okay so you
don't have actually have a strategy in
place okay and the third thing
is
hubris you don't think anyone can
challenge you you don't think you can
lose a
war okay and so the idea of hubis is
this right now America has this huge
Empire and it's refusing to spend the
necessary resources to protect the
Empire so for example the US Navy okay
1945 it had 7,600 ships today guess what
guys it has
475 these 475 ships must go around all
around the world to protect shipping
lanes
okay the US military in 19 in 1991
during the first person Gulf War had two
million soldiers today has one 1.3
million
soldiers okay so in other words if
America ever fights a war a major war
it's going to have a lot of problems the
other thing is that America doesn't even
have manufacturing capacity anymore okay
it's not it doesn't have any factories
anymore which means that if it fights a
war it can't fight a war for a very long
time so the example is that for every
for every ship that America makes China
can make 300
ships okay America no longer has this
manufacturing capacity that it had
during World World War II okay so in
other
words why will the military agree to the
stupid war in Iran because it's
overcommitted it has no strategy and
it's because it's
arrogant all right and it and and the
military is like this because of what
happened in 2003 shock and
all does does that make sense to you
guys right so next class we will look at
what the Iran War will look like and I
guarantee you that shakan all is not
going to work in Iran all right and but
I'll explain why next class any
questions before we end for the
day oh so Selen asked a great question
what's the difference between
uh the people who believe in the first
Theory and the second theory okay okay
and the answer is this the people who
believe the in the in the first Theory
came from an older generation okay this
is a generation that fought in World War
II and who fought the Cold War so they
understand what war looks like war is
really
bloody and it's terrible and we must do
our best to avoid war okay the second
generation
2003 are individuals who don't know what
war is okay like if you actually look at
videos from 2003 the war it actually
looks like a video game you understand
you don't actually see what they saw in
Vietnam which was all these soldiers
losing their arms and crying okay I mean
the images from Vietnam were just
terrible it was hard for people to watch
but the the the the golf war in 2003 it
was just a voo game it was just like
things getting blown up okay you don't
actually see the people dying and again
only 20 people died 20 soldiers died in
the um in
2003 okay
so uh in other words
unfortunately America has headed towards
disaster okay because the people in
charge have no experience they they
don't know what war
is and they don't know what the hores of
war is and they've inherited a lot of
money and they want to enjoy the money
okay they want to have fun okay does
that make sense okay all right great so
I'll see you guys next class